[Music]
i'm stephen blackwood and i have the
great honor today to be here with sir
roger penrose and dr jordan peterson
let's get right down to it jordan i know
you have questions you're keen to pose
to sir roger over to you
yeah well i've wanted to talk to a
theoretical physicist for about 30 years
and
so i'm pretty happy that you're the
theoretical physicist that i get to talk
to
i'm probably not representative
well that might be even better so i want
to jump right into it um
a colleague and friend of mine
is a ai engineer and a computer engineer
and he's built a lot of the world's
great chips iphone chip
first 64-bit chip the alpha back in 1985
and we were having a conversation i said
i was coming to
meet you
and that you and i don't want to put
words in your mouth believe me but that
you believe that
consciousness is in some fundamental
sense non-computational and i asked him
what he thought about that and part of
the reason i asked him is because he's
of all the people i've ever met and
maybe of all the people in the world
he's the person who's done most to
build arguably brain-like algorithmic
systems and so i asked him if he thought
that there was a distinction between
the algorithmic
computation of cognition per se
and whatever consciousness might be
and he thought it was
algorithmic all the way down
and
i understand that you don't believe that
i also went with him a couple of times
to a consciousness conference in tucson
where hamlet spoke so we got familiar
with that line of reasoning
and
i also understand i believe that part of
the reason that you think that
consciousness is necessarily
non-computational is because of
goodell's theorem
and so
maybe we could we could enter theirs
what it i'm very curious about your
proposition that
consciousness per se is
non-computational and i'm curious about
why you came to that conclusion and if
you think that's a warranted conclusion
what what you think about that in
relationship to these complex ai systems
and
and also in relationship to goodell's
theorem well i've never seen the
argument refuted i've just talked to
people who've never really understood it
as far as i know no the argument goes
back to when i was a graduate student
and i was doing pure mathematics
algebraic geometry
and i went to three courses which were
nothing to do with what i was supposed
to be doing
one of them was a wonderful course by
hermann bundy on general relativity
which had a big influence on what i did
later on one was a talk by the great
physicist paul dirac
and that taught me about quantum
mechanics
and their third one was of course by a
logician called steen
and he taught me about
turing machines the notion of
computability what it is and how you
understand that
and
the girdle theorem
and i had heard vaguely about the girdle
theorem previously
and had been rather worried because it
seemed to show that there were things in
mathematics that you couldn't prove
what i learned was that it's not like
that at all well it is like that in a
sense
if you lay down the rules of what you
call a proof and if those rules are such
that they could be checked by a computer
checked whether they've been correctly
applied by a computer so computation
rules in that sense
then
you can you can construct a sentence
this is what girdle did which
the by the way it's constructed
you can see that if you trust the rules
let's say if you believe that the rules
do
if they say yes you've proved it tick
then you believe it's correct let's say
if you have trust in the rules that
trust extends beyond the rules in other
words
you can see that a certain statement is
true
by virtue of your belief that the rules
only give you truths
yet
that statement is underrivable
unprovable using the rules that that
statement of faith about the rules
it's not a statement of faith i'm sorry
i didn't understand well
the faith is it's not a faith you
understand the rules you check them you
say yes that's okay if that rule is
correctly applied i agree it does
you know it's a lot it's a
it it's a a rule which is within
something that you believe to be
appropriate
and this rule it's built up out of
things like this which nobody would
dispute say okay if you follow those
rules
and it says yes that's a proof then you
believe that this thing that it says yes
it's a proof is actually a true
statement
so does a proof really mean that it's
true
if you believe that
that
that conviction that the proofs actually
do what they're supposed to do
gives you something beyond the rules
themselves okay that that's sorry that's
what i was referring to with this with
the word faith is that the statement of
belief
well i i guess i'm wondering what what
do you think it is that cons that come
under constitutes that belief
okay and why the word understanding
specifically because that's the thing in
some sense that's outside the system the
understanding
yes it is
because you can see it is because
it's the understanding that the rules
give you only truths
that enables you to
understand
that this girdle statement is actually
true
and so
the is that belief in that truth of that
proof that is one of the things that
goodell
pointed out would be necessarily outside
any system that's both what is it formal
logical and coherent
what shows it shows that the i mean i i
read it in this particular way i don't
think he said it quite like this but i
read it in the following way
that understanding whatever that word
means
is not computational
okay okay it's not that that is what
it's not the following of rules it's
something else okay so let me ask you a
question about that so
this is a three-prong question okay yes
it seems to me that there's a high
probability that the future is actually
indeterminately different than the
present and the past that it's actually
unpredictably different
oh this is a different question
now you're talking about determinism yes
yes but but i think it's i it seems to
me that it's tied to this idea that
computation can be complete and
algorithmic i don't think it can be
because if the future differs
in a in a fundamental manner an
unpredictable manner from the present or
the past then a deterministic
algorithmic system can't maintain a grip
on the horizon of the future
and and and i have another part of that
question but it's a different question
so i think we i think it's important to
distinguish these things yes because up
to this point i was not talking about
indeterminism no no no i was talking
about rules
well
just yes or no and i mean it's not a
question of
maybe or
i mean it isn't even talking about the
laws of physics at this stage that's the
second step i feel like
i was i guess i looked forward to
something like the the potential
necessary function of consciousness
so because one of the things
consciousness seems to do from a
neurophysiological perspective for
example we tend to become conscious of
our procedural errors
and so consciousness becomes alerted to
the errors and then zeros in on the
source of the error in some sense and
corrects it and so it looks to me like
it's something like a correction system
for help for underlying algorithmic
systems
so for example if you practice a a motor
routine for a long time you build
specialized algorithmic machinery in
your brain that runs it but maybe you
you put in an error you're playing a
difficult piano phrase for example and
you stumble over a note you've
automatized that you play it you listen
and you hear the anomaly which is the
error your consciousness focuses in on
that
a large brain area will activate
as a consequence of becoming aware of
that error then when you practice the
new routine that's corrected the brain
area will shrink and shrink and shrink
until it's a small part of the brain
usually in the back of the left
hemisphere and now you've built another
automated machine to
to play out that phrase
and consciousness i think it was
whitehead who said that
that at least the purpose of
consciousness although he might have
used thought was to increase the number
of things that we can do without
consciousness or thought
but it seems to be this horizon
phenomena and and the reason i was
asking about
the indeterminacy of the future was
twofold is that
if the future is deterministic then an
algorithm mixed system could in
principle adapt to it
but i don't it doesn't seem to me that
the future can be predictable and i
think that that might be grounded in
something like quantum indeterminacy
because there isn't a fundamental
determinism that propagates all the way
up
so
well you see i mean we have to
the things i was talking about up to
this point but not to do they weren't
even to do with the laws of physics so
that's a separate question i mean it did
relate to that which is my own views
certainly did
depend on that
but um
the question of determinism is a
separate issue
and
the normal way we look at quantum
mechanics is it does involve an
indeterminism
um
which you can have a theory which does
that too but that's different you see if
it's just indeterministic
it um
it's not it's not connected but you see
the the girdle argument is to do things
where you
have definite rules you you
can check whether these rules have been
followed or not
and the question is whether it coincides
with your
understanding about what things are true
or false in mathematics so that's what
it's to do with
now you see you can
question how you
you move from that into other aspects of
what consciousness does and also the
question you were referring to is when
something's automatic and your penis can
play things and obviously where the
little finger goes next is not something
that he or she decides to do it's all
largely controlled by the cerebellum
probably
which as far as we know is entirely
unconscious
so the
greater number of neurons in the brain
which are in the cerebellum
seem
not to be acting according to
conscious
actions at all it's something completely
unknown right yes
that's a very strange thing that you
know people make the case as well that
there's some simple relationship between
neuronal function and consciousness but
as you pointed out the cerebellum does
the cerebellar activity doesn't seem to
be conscious at all and then you're
there's a tremendous amount of neurons
in your autonomic nervous system
distributed throughout your body and
there there may be some consciousness
associated with that but it's not
particularly acute and most of the time
it's entirely unconscious and the
autonomic nervous system is running your
digestive system and your heart and all
of these
inner automated systems and it's
interesting too because
often becoming consciously aware of a
highly functional
unconscious system actually impairs its
function rather than improving it that
could be yeah sure
that's i'm not quite sure
what this tells us about consciousness
it just tells us certain things are not
conscious which are
controlled by neurons in the brain and
and so it's a different issue right but
i might just jump in to ask you if you
would say a word or two more about
why it is that
consciousness cannot be reduced simply
to mechanistic uh processes well you see
i'm very careful to say i'm not talking
about consciousness in all its aspects
yes for example i mean i have nothing to
say about the perception of the color
green for instance
i mean
sure
there's something going on which makes
green have a certain impression on one
but this is not what i'm talking about
and probably most of the things that we
think about when we talk about
consciousness are not what i'm talking
about so i'm only talking about a very
specific
part of what consciousness does
and the argument is that if if this is
something which is
not
a
computational process
then it sort of sheds a question mark on
the whole thing
but it's only very specific to the
question of understanding so i tend to
make that point clear
and understanding is something which in
the certainly in the normal usage of the
word
implies
conscious and you wouldn't say of a
device normally that it understands
something
without it being aware of something and
aware means being conscious of it so
that's just normal usage and i'm going
along with that
so i don't know
what most of these words mean
but i would say
that
understanding is something which
requires consciousness
yes there's one way into this
to speak about i mean so much of our
thinking of course is calculative
there's a there's a goal there we're
calculating how to get to it um and so
there's a huge amount of life that is
that is that is like that but
to then ask the question about why this
is a goal or why this is worthy of being
a goal or what would make it worthy of
being a goal or what would
make that worthy of being a
justification for that to be a goal the
kinds of thinking that you have to
engage in
in order to reflect upon the nature of
the ends and purposes
is distinct from the kinds of thinking
you engage in to calculate your way to a
goal and that seems to point towards the
the realm or a kind of thinking or
awareness that is clearly distinct from
a
simply mechanistic
uh calculations yes i mean
i i certainly wouldn't disagree with
that
it's just it's hard to know
whether
those things could be
put into a computational system
the reason for concentrating on this
very specific area is that i can say
something about it that's all
so the particular area is is um
mathematical proof i see most people
don't bother themselves with
mathematical proofs so and they're
conscious too so i'm certainly not
saying that's a
an
indicator of consciousness i mean i'm
saying it is
something which requires consciousness
but i'm completely accepted there all
sorts of other aspects of consciousness
which are going on all the time and
which are much more important
i've gone along with that too but it's
just that if you can find something
in what consciousness seems to do
which is not which is demonstrably not
computational
that's saying something
and that's the limited little thing i'm
trying to say now you you started
working with hammer off as i understand
it to try to provide something
approximating a localization or a new
neurophysiological account of what this
non-deterministic process might be in ah
but i didn't say that's usually
non-deterministic that's different okay
it's very easy to confuse it well and i
am confused about them apparently now
you see non-deterministic means that
rules
don't have a clear statement about what
happens next and maybe there is a choice
about what happens next
and that choice might be random
or maybe choice in some
more
personal sense that you have a reason i
don't know
but usually one talks about randomness
there you say that the theory does not
have a complete
description of what it tells you happens
in the future
because there isn't a random element in
it and the way quantitative huge random
yes in the future that's what normally
the way in which one talks about quantum
mechanics normally i mean i have
and that's a truly random feature in
not predictable in current quantum
mechanics that's correct yes
okay so that's what i was referring to
when i was referring to the in like the
indeterminacy of the future horizon it
was sorry it was that randomness that i
was trying yes well you see
i mean but this is another question you
could have a random device
which is otherwise computational
i mean just you put in at certain points
okay
do something randomly the thing is that
don't think
an interesting question there i don't
think that gives you anything
in the way of establishing results
which which seem to be a
non-computational process like with the
girdle thing okay so so okay so there's
an evolutionary
answer to the problem of emergent
randomness
and
the answer is
so
a mosquito mosquito is a good example
yeah any or fish any animal that lays a
tremendous number of eggs that could
conceivably
march to maturity
so
there's genetic mutation in all so maybe
let's say just for the sake of argument
that a given mosquito lays a million
eggs fertile eggs in its lifetime
now there's variation in those
mosquito patterns
and at least a certain amount of that
variation is random that's a consequence
and it's actually a consequence i would
say of events that are actually
manifesting themselves in some sense at
a quantum level because at least some of
the mutations are caused by solar
by radiation and so there's disruption
at a molecular level and so evolution
seems to be able to use
the admixture of randomness into
structure as a means of dealing with the
inter determinancy of the future and to
some degree it does that through death
right because
of those million mosquitoes on average
only one managed just to propagate
itself to reproduction or we'd be
knee-deep in mosquitoes and like no and
sam was saying yes but what i'm trying
to say is that what's going on with
consciousness is different from that
because i don't see how this
you know you're putting randomness and
in the way you're suggesting
and clearly that is an important
aspect to evolution and so on i
certainly wouldn't wouldn't deny that at
all
but it's not the same thing
so that that consciousness isn't
producing randomness in response to
indigenous fantasy yes it's it's when i
say non-computational i don't mean
that it's random at certain times
i mean something quite different so what
okay let's let's zero in on that so well
because i'm very curious about what you
do mean i mean this is obviously a
tremendously important distinction
between
algorithmic computate the computational
algorithmic domain and something that's
in some sense outside of it and and i'm
struggling to understand
at the most detailed level let's say
what
how you
how you envision
the
the structure and function of
consciousness or maybe just the function
it's not producing mere random variants
and i i that can't be because random is
too widespread so at least at the very
least
so for example if you study creative
people we've done a lot of this
there's in some sense more randomness in
their
speech
because
imagine that with
if you utter a given word there's a
certain probability that another word
will emerge in the in the field around
that the creative people
use lower probability
concepts and words in their approach so
there's a kind of randomness they go
farther out into the word association
field and that does help them generate
more creative solutions
but that's not if that becomes
unconstrained to too great a degree you
get well maybe like a manic creativity
that's that's counterproductive and and
too random people are jumping too much
from disconnected point to disconnected
point
and so
so consciousness doesn't seem to be
creative consciousness doesn't seem to
be a mere random walk
so that's a psychological take on that
but so what do you think is what you
think
i'm still struggling to understand what
you think consciousness does
it it does understand
yes
you see i think probably you're trying
to make me be more specific than i can
be
because i don't know
what what it is that
how to make a device that
can understand something
so i'm just trying to say that whatever
understanding is
it's not a computational process and
that's the argument okay okay
it's not so you're not trying to specify
what it might be you're just saying it
has to be something that's known
computation yes that's right yes oh is
there it okay is there a fundamental
link i mean when we say
non-compu it's not it is not
non-computational
does that mean
or does that not mean by definition that
consciousness is some
deep level is free
no
that's right i'm not i mean these are
open questions i'm not saying that i
mean maybe there is an aspect of
indeterminism in it and that's
could be
um but that's not what i'm saying
and it's the trouble is i think it's not
a concept which people appreciate
usually so i can give you examples of
non-computational things and the one of
the examples i often give
is if you take
you take an imagine a
pattern of squares equal squares or just
a normal square array and you can
consider a finite shape made out of
squares
i think it's called a polyamino
shape made out of squares
and you if you're given a finite set
of these
polyaminos
and the question is can you cover the
plane with those shapes only those
shapes no gaps no overlaps
now that question
the answer yes or no the answer is
definite yes or no either you can or you
can't
but it's not an algorithmic process
it's it's shown mathematically that
there is no algorithm
which can tell you yes or no whether
these shapes will cover the plane
okay so when i was talking to my
brother-in-law
i was talking to him about these
ai systems
that learn how to recognize let's say
cats from photographs
he told me there is no way of
algorithmically determining
the program
that the machine learning systems will
eventually apply to the problem of
identifying cats in a photograph but if
you let the ai neural networks run
and then you analyze their output you
often get something that resembles an
algorithmic program as an output that
you could have hypothetically calculated
if you could have specified the search
space
it's something like that but there's no
way of there's no way of doing that
without letting the program
do its walk through the domain of cat
photographs with its differentially
awaited neural network architecture you
can't a priori predict it
yeah well
i still don't think it's the same thing
um
i mean i could certainly give it
different shapes and you can say
tell the machine you know which of these
will tell the plan which won't
now will that
learn to give you correct answers
well probably usually it does i suppose
once it's tiled you could formalize the
process by which it was tiled
right because you could you could you
could you could describe the
the mechanisms or the order in which the
tiles were located then the rotation of
them you could specify it after it had
all been laid down
and i think that's analogous to what the
ai systems seem to be doing when they're
learning to perceive but the trouble is
that it's not
the message whereby you can tile the
plane uh
i mean just the theorems tell you that
they you can't put you can't put them on
the computer i mean you might get the
thing which works most of the time right
quite possibly well so in those tiling
problems that you're describing yeah and
so that's that is i see i guess i kind
of see why you're interested in the
tiling issue so that has to do in some
sense with the ability to
to map a surface with a certain
representational form
and so if you have these tiles that you
described and you're trying to to
completely cover a given surface that's
a mapping problem i see what you're
doing with that
are there different ways that you could
conceivably solve that problem so
okay so so even if you do converge on a
solution you haven't converged on the
only solution oh absolutely i mean there
was an earlier result which showed that
if it were true
that any way of tiling that plane
with these shapes with say some given
set of shape finite set of shapes if it
tiles the plane
it can do it you can do it periodically
with a repeating pattern
if that were true
then there would be an algorithm but
it's not true because there are certain
ways of tiling a plane which do not have
a repeating pattern repeating patterns
so now that's so cool because i was
wondering today i was wondering why in
the world is he obsessed with tiles
what's going on
well the fact that you're that the tiles
are they're essentially you're
essentially mapping uh an an area with a
with a predetermined concept in some
sense that's that that's the tile shape
and you said it can be non-repeating and
still solvable but you see the one in
front of the mass building that's an
example
that's an example of a tiling set only
two different shapes there i mean these
aren't polyominos but never mind about
that those two shapes
will tie right out to infinity
but there is no way of doing this which
is periodic
and you can see in it it's almost you
see this sort of piece so how do people
actually do it then like because there's
another way of telling you how to do it
with the with the tiling so do you so
you designed the tiling in front of the
building so do you actually tell the
workmen how to start the tile and then
how do they figure out how to do it or
you had a plan for the whole thing and
you you devised the plan for the whole
thing yes so you provided the map yes
okay
how in the world did you get interested
do you have any idea how you initially
got interested in the tiling problem yes
would you say it certainly was this
computability question
that is the connection yeah
i had learnt i think i've seen
an article in the maths maths reviews
this reviews mathematical papers and so
on and i'd seen that there somebody had
produced a set of tiles which would
tile the plane only only non
in a non-periodic way
and i hadn't seen what they were like
and there was a conversation i i think
it was just
just after i'd i'd been appointed to my
chair here the raspberry chair
but before i'd taken it up
and i had a conversation with with an
american mathematician
um
and he had
told me in detail about
i think there's a mathematician called
raphael robinson had got the number down
to six and he'd got a set of six tiles
which would only tell the plane in a
non-repeating way
and he said that raphael robinson this
was simon cochin who's an american
mathematician and he said that rapha
robinson was somebody who liked to get
the number to the smallest number he was
sort of perfectionist in this way
and he said he's got this wrong it he
started it started out with several
thousands you see and he got it under
six
and you're pretty pleased with that
and i said well i can do it five
i happen to know i had a set with six
you see but i knew that i could reduce
it to five how did you know
how did i know that you could reduce it
to five
because the way that the
i mean it's just a technical point there
was a certain shape for matching
and this shape only fitted into one
other tile
so that i could glue that the ones with
it's just a slight detail point let's
get glued some of the tiles together to
make them five
and when you're when you're mapping the
plane yeah do you map it to the precise
borders of the plane or can there be
overlap
you know what i mean can it be messy on
the edges or or are you trying to
precisely cover let's say a rectangle it
keeps on going beyond the edge and then
you cut cut it along the edge yeah okay
okay that's right okay yeah yeah okay
so now you also had some interaction
interactions at least at arm's length
with with escher
oh yeah yeah so what i read was that you
and you and your father had been
interested in escher's work
and you worked out with him
the
ever-ascending staircase
which by the way seems to me quite
similar especially to the music in box
third brandenburg concerto which and i
talked to a musician this week about how
bach managed to make this continual
ascending spiral that never really goes
up that's true there is a thing like
that yeah yeah right yes
so and then you sent the drawings of the
staircase to asher
well the story was a little bit longer
than that because i i had been at this
i was a graduate student i think in my
second year i can't quite remember and i
and the colleague went to amsterdam to
go to the international congress of
mathematicians which happened every four
years
and at this congress
i happened to see one of my lecturers
and he had a catalogue which had one of
these action pictures and what on earth
is that you see and he said well this
exhibition in the fangoth museum
by this artist m.c escher
never heard of him before i went to see
the exhibition i was absolutely blown
over by these pictures
one in particular i think was called
relativity
and i came away thinking
gosh that's amazing
i went whether i could do something a
little bit different that i hadn't
actually seen in in the exhibition
and there so i tried to make a
construction with bridges and roads
going into possible ways
and i simplified it down to this thing
that people refer to as a tri-bar i've
seen the dry bar and
i showed my father i mean i didn't know
that there's a
swedish
artist called oscar wrightsville who had
done things very similar earlier
but
escher didn't know about him either but
anyway um and there are other artists
who've done things like if you look
carefully in in the old
there's a breakwar which which has a
picture of gallows and they're it's
joined up differently in the top yes
i've seen that i've seen that picture
so there are other people who had played
with these ideas but i hadn't quite seen
it in isha
and so my father and i wrote an article
he he developed the staircase was his
actually
he was designing buildings and then he
produced the staircase which went round
and round
and we decided to write a paper on this
we had no idea what the subject was what
journal did we send it to so my father
said well i happen to know the editor of
the british journal of psychology so
let's call it psychology
so we sent it to them
and they accepted it he said he thought
he could get the attitude to accept it
they did and this was we gave reference
to ash's the catalogue
to escha's exhibition
and then my father had a con
correspondence with airship with letters
going backwards and forwards
and then i think i
was in driving in the netherlands for
some other conference i think
and i was curious
and i
when i was reasonably close to escher i
phoned him up i got the phone number
from my father
and he was very nice and he invited me
and my then wife
to
tea and and he i just had a chat with
him and
he he sat at one end of a long table i
was the other end and he had two piles
of prince and he said well this pile
i don't have many left i'm afraid
and he pushed the other part of me
choose one
so i sort of went through these things
and i picked one out pretty hard to
choose one out of all that
and i chose one called fish and scales
[ __ ]
he was actually rather pleased because
he said well most people don't
understand that one
so i felt a bit flattered by that
but this
i then gave him a set of little
pieces of
just one shape
and
i
i gave him a set of them and said well
can you tile with those
and then a little while later he wrote
to me and said he'd
seen how to do it but he wants to know
what the
underlying principle was
so i did i wouldn't pray that i was a
very bad correspondent it took me a
little while before i got back to him
but i showed him the the
what it was based on and on the basis of
that he produced what i believe with his
last
watercolor maybe for this last picture
as far as i know thing called ghosts
which is based on on this uh
it's the only tiling as far as i know
that he ever did which is what's called
non-isohedral
you see you usually did periodic ones
but they're periodic in the strong sense
that if you find a shape
the next time you see it it has the same
relation to the pattern as a whole so
you could
move this one into that shape and the
whole pattern goes with it into itself
but the one i showed him was what's
called non-isohedral that you can have
different instances of the shape
so this one has a different relation to
the pattern as a whole
from that one
and so if i move this one into that i
can't bring the whole pattern
along with it
so you have two different
roles that the shape plays in the last
one of his pictures
showed this
so i'm curious too so
this
about about two things now i'm
interested in why
you're so fascinated by the relationship
of
a geometric shape that can be arrayed in
a variety of different manners to this
underlying problem of mapping like
so you're reducing
you're reducing or establishing a
relationship between the problem of
mapping a large terrain
to the utilization of
like
very stringently defined
what would you call them
representational systems or that that's
a geometric form what what is the
geometric form
conceptually
in relationship to the problem of
mapping
well you have a shape and then you have
certain rules about which fit pieces
will fit next to it
but there's certain freedom in that rule
you could put this one that way or
another way you see
and you know if it's just if it's
a shape which very clearly has to fit
that way next to it then it just repeats
you see but if there's some freedom as
to what the next one will do
then you might have to make that choice
and certain choices will run you into
difficulties later
and other choices maybe will allow you
to continue
is there a relationship that between
that and what composers do with music
because i mean there's a certain well
there's a certain repeating determinancy
in music but obviously a composer just
doesn't take a pattern and repeat it
indefinitely they take a pattern and the
pattern seems to allow for
some choice in movement from that
pattern forward well maybe i don't know
i mean it said this i mean what makes a
piece of music into a good piece of
music
i mean i have no idea that's that's a
much deeper issue well we do know we do
know a bit about it we know that if it's
too simple and repetitive it you your
interest gets exhausted yes exactly it
gets stale very rapidly and then
as it moves towards purely unpredictable
it becomes indistinguishable from noise
so there's some place in between there
and you could probably move on that
place where you get
some ultimately harmonious relationship
of predictable form and
well something like the play of novelty
that seems to me to be analogous to that
possibility of shifting the shapes in
this tiling problem i mean i think music
is tiling something yeah it's a
representational form no that's probably
some connection it's just that music
i mean there's so much more freedom as
to what you do you you see with this
with these tiling shapes it's forced on
you that you know either it fits or it
doesn't you see it with music it's much
more subtle
right i would i would hate to make too
much of a
leap yeah
yeah yeah fair enough one more question
along that line now that
that triangle you made
yes now what's the relationship between
those paradoxical forms and the tiling
problem
not much
because they seem to be they they're i
mean there's a play of of representation
an image there
i mean one of the things i've been
wondering i looked at all your diverse
contributions and i thought wow there's
a lot of things happening in a lot of
different places but there must be some
there's something that's not random
there's something at work
that's kind of a uniting principle that
might be i don't know it might be the
problem that you're trying to solve in
some
in some deepest way that's uniting all
these elements of exploration and
interest
i don't know you're asking too hard a
question i don't know i mean sometimes
i don't see any
overriding principle
i mean there's a sort of thing
you know something feels right now why
do you why does it feel right i mean
that could be
something very subtle
yeah yeah maybe wrong too or maybe maybe
they are wrong that yes yes
it seems to me that that also is related
in some important sense psychologically
to that notion of understanding you know
the feeling that it's right it's it's
like it's interesting that it can be
wrong but it's also interesting that it
can be a predictor
of i got a student a student she was
very creative
and she would come up with hypotheses
that were damn good
but she was more creative than the
typical psychologist and i don't say
that in a denigrating way i mean she was
more like an artist than a researcher
and then what she would do is spend like
six months writing out the algorithmic
pathway to that conclusion even though
that is not how she derived it but she
had a pretty unerring ability to jump
forward to the right place with her
intuition and it's something like i
think it's something like a deep form of
pattern recognition you know you don't
need the full pattern to infer what the
pattern might be you can have a sparse
representation of it leap to what might
be analogous to a tiling solution i
suppose and that that seems to be
something related to the accuracy of
intuition i know when people become
schizotypal for example
they're
they
and paranoid that also happens in
paranoia they have a lot of intuitions
about patterns that might be there
but most of them are wrong and so it's
like their pattern recognition system
has become
well it's it's exceeded the limits of
its capacity for accuracy and is
starting to see pattern in in what's
truly random
you know prediction error yeah well may
i ask there's a
i think one important distinction here
from what i can understand
sir roger is is uh
what the nature of understanding is here
is not
it's not to be simply reduced to belief
or
or
or intuition though it may be related to
them
when
one understands something let's say
that's the simple equation that two plus
two equals four
it's not a belief that that is true
understanding is operating at a level
that is beyond belief it has a certainty
and inner certainty that is not
subject to doubt fundamentally um
and what i was wondering if it might be
helpful
just for the sake also of the people who
may subsequently watch this conversation
if you would be willing sir roger to
to
give us a a sense of your
your uh
the way you describe the three spheres
of of of matter
and mind and mathematics uh as that
might give us a basis for some
quite rich conversation subsequently
well maybe
you want me to describe the picture i
mean
please
well this was just a way of thinking
about
the relationship between mathematics and
the physical world and
the world of
conscious perception
and
i was regarding each of each of these
was a sort of world
i mean whether that's a useful way or
not it was just
helpful to me
and there is the mathematical world and
i take a very platonic view here that
the mathematical world exists
independently of us and so when we find
a mathematical result it's it's more
like a discovery than than an
intervention so you it's there already
and you find it
so this is certainly a feeling that as
far as i'm aware most mathematicians
have
and the truths are there
and they're there independently of us
and if we're lucky we can
find one of these truths and and see why
it is a truth
now
that's one thing now then there's the
physical world and the physical world
the more we learn about it
the more we find that it operates
according to very precise mathematical
laws
but yet it's very small you see if you
look at a mathematical journal you find
it's
almost entirely full of things which
have nothing whatsoever to do
with physical world they're playing
around with mathematics for its own sake
that part of the mathematical world
which actually does have direct
relevance to the way that what physical
world operates
is a small part of it so i have a
picture of this mathematical world and a
tiny bit of that
comes and
imposes itself or whatever you like to
explains or whatever you'd like to say
the physical world so the more we learn
about the physical world the more we see
it is driven
or
acts according to these very specific
tiny parts of the mathematical world
and the second thing is
in that physical world which seems to be
operating according to mathematics
there are entities
which seem to be able to perceive and
understand and have consciousness
so the
the acquisition of consciousness in
whatever way
is a small path you see the world
consists of rocks and things like that
which don't seem to have any of this
quality but there are certain creatures
things
such as people in this room and
elsewhere and probably
other animals which may have less of it
than humans but on the other hand i'd
certainly think they have
consciousness
some of them
so but still it's a tiny part of the
physical world which seems to have
access or whatever the right
thing is seems to be able to
be
a certain sense this world of
consciousness
so it's again a small part of that
but there's only a tiny world part of
the conscious
activity
which is concerned with mathematics so i
had this picture which is sort of meant
to be slightly paradoxical that each
world
in a certain sense
comes from a little bit bit of the world
preceding it
and so it's drawn in a way which is like
this impossible triangle which is a
looks like a paradox that's only a
little joke in a way i i don't know how
how much depth there is to that
um
and i i rather like to depict it in that
way
so this this this
so stop me when i'm wrong okay
all right so
it seems to me that
the mathematical reality is something
like the observation of the pattern
regularity between things it's not the
things themselves or the the physical
which which well i'm thinking about the
mathematical representation of the
physical world
so because
things there are things obviously but
there are things in relationship to one
another yeah and the relationships
between the things like the pattern that
your tiles yeah compose is just as real
as the tiles
right but it consists of the
relationship between the tiles
and is it the representation of the
relationship between things that's part
of that mathematical world rather than
i know it could be
you see powerful it's a physical thing
that's just sitting in front of the last
building so that's that's a physical
thing
but it is represent it represents a
mathematical idea
which only
gives you the idea i could see oh these
tiles fit together in such such a way
and these are parts of the euclidean
plane and the euclidean plane is a
concept we don't actually have it
physically
but you can see
by looking at the tiles carefully enough
and see how they fit together
that this is a mathematical thing you're
looking at in a way and that this
mathematical thing
would allow you
to continue if you understand what's
going on
indefinitely so the entire euclidean
plane could be covered according to the
rules of those shapes you see okay so
let me ask you another question about
that then so
is the physical world
one tiling solution
to the plane of mathematical possibility
i guess it in a sense
i mean it's slightly
you see it's not really talking about
the laws of physics there you it's only
in the sense that euclidean geometry is
a pretty good approximation that's all
it's saying
i mean there's not much physics going on
there
you might say well what what makes these
tiles
some of them shine and some not shine or
something like that i mean it's more
like physics
but the actual
design that's being used there
it's it's been put there by human beings
according to what another human being
said they should where they should lay
them down
and that was driven by a certain
mathematical concept
but it's different from the
way that mathematics underlies
the laws of physics
and that's quite different
it might be if you took one of those
tiles and threw it across
or how you'd be pretty hard to do
because they're quite heavy
but the way that would
move in the air before it came down and
crashed
that would be a clear indication of a
physical law where in which gravitation
behaves
and then the way the thing holds
together the
law that holds the
makes these tiles solid
be something to do with the
um well quantum mechanics to do with the
ways that the
atoms are constructed and how they
connect with other atoms and what makes
them solid rather than a fluid
or something like that so that would be
the way that mathematics
drives the physics it's it's it's
general laws rather than a specific
thing i think that's what it was that's
what i said don't do it because in some
sense
and
i could obviously be wrong about this
but
the physical reality seems to constrain
the mathematical possibility
because there's only some mathematical
rules that govern the behavior of actual
objects even though there's all sorts of
possible mathematics that could govern
the action of all sorts of hypothetical
objects
right so so it's
so imagine if there's an underlying
i can't help but think this is
associated with this many worlds idea
but if there's an underlying metaverse
of mathematical possibility
you get the emergence of something like
a what would you say
one concretized exploration of that
possibility space and that
now establishes a relationship between
one element of that mathematical
possibility space and
and
well in reality itself doesn't exhaust
the search space but it's and it seems
to me that that's analogous to this
tiling problem in some sense
i think it's i don't know i can't help
saying i think it's
really very different from what one is
trying to do in mathematical physics so
in mathematical physics you're looking
for general laws
which
seem
individual instances
agree with those laws so that
an object like one of the tiles that are
being used outside maths building
um
and the trouble is that it depends on
detailed laws about the atoms which
construct the tiles and so which has
nothing to do with what we're talking
about here
i don't think it is
well i guess i was wondering partly
because there's these fine-tuning
arguments you know and and the question
arises well there's lots of ways these
phenomenon
phenomena could be
interrelated
but in reality it turns out that there
is a very finite and constrained number
of ways that they are actually related
and those those are the fundamental laws
and then the question arises well why
that set of constraints and not you know
some other set of constraints that seems
equally probably probable statistically
you know if it was a sample of the
mathematical domain
yeah i guess i'm i have to understand
what you're saying a bit better
um
i mean you could say okay there's this
building well the one we're in now which
has in front of it a certain tiling i
mean that's
if you're going to explain that i mean
that's very different from what
mathematical physicists do and they're
just looking for general principles
right and the as far as we're aware
those general principles are not
violated in
in what's been going on in this building
however that's not entirely
what i would think
because what's going on in this building
and so on is an
implication of what's going on in
people's heads
and this does have to do with
consciousness
and what's going on in consciousness
in my view is not yet
part of current physics
so i'm trying to say
that although we have very good theories
about how things behave bodies behave
and
they're not good enough yet
to tell us how
the conscious human brain operates
so do you
allow your imagination to wander into
the domain of metaphysical speculation
about that i mean because you're you're
you're making a case yeah i mean i i was
talking some to some divinity scholars
the other day and they were laughing i
suppose about physicists who say
with regard to the big bang and the
hypothetical emergence of everything out
of nothing that give us one free miracle
and we'll proceed from there and
so i mean there is speculation among
physicists that the laws of physics
don't apply to whatever the state of
existence was before the
universe emerged into being and you're
making a case now as well that
consciousness itself
may not be able to be encapsulated
within the realm of our current physical
theories is so what do you think the
metaphysical
or do you or let me try and get i'd have
to unpack something here because we're
venturing on the different topics yes i
know which is the question of the big
bang yes which i have a different view
on that from what you normally okay so
but that's what that'd be fun we can
talk about that if you want to yeah
that's interesting topic to talk about
but that's really different
and then as far as i don't even see a
connection as things stand
from what i'm worrying about in
consciousness
both stand outside the laws of known
physics in some sense let me say
something else which outside the laws
are known physics and
this is not something that people
normally even recognize as a problem
i mean they do but they shove it under
the carpet
which is what's known as the collapse of
the wave function
now you see current quantum mechanics
strictly speaking is an inconsistent
theory
that's rather brutal way of saying what
einstein and schrodinger and even dirac
said that quantum mechanics is
incomplete
and the way to explain this is
okay there's a wonderful equation which
tells you how things stay a state
evolves in quantum mechanics called the
schrodinger equation now the schrodinger
equation tells you if you know what the
state of a system is now
the schroding equation tells you what it
will be tomorrow if you like
the evolution of that state is governed
by this wonderful equation due to irving
schroedinger
the trouble is that it doesn't
that's to say
the way physicists usually use the
schrodinger equation is to work out
certain probabilities of what an
observation on the system would tell you
so what you have to do is you wheel out
of the cupboard
and a measuring device
in this measuring device
you set it on the
the system which is evolving according
to the schroding equation and it
measures it
and the process of measurement does not
follow the schrodinger equation
it gives you a probabilistic answer this
or this or this
that's another outside the system
problem it's certainly outside the
schrodinger equation right right right
and schrodinger was terribly worried
about this i mean he produced his cat in
the box and all sorts of things you see
he clearly realized there was a problem
as did einstein there's no question
about that
some others didn't well they took a
different view they said look we don't
understand the theory well enough and
that's more that we're saying we're
schroedinger's not saying that you're
saying we understand it well enough to
see that that's not the way the world
operates when you make a measurement on
a system
it does not follow the schrodinger
equation and that's what people
understand about quantum mechanics
but it's it's a sort of
vague set of rules about
it doesn't tell you what constitutes a
measurement right it's a problem right
yeah that's a big trouble that's the big
problem yeah yeah they say if you do a
measurement then it just becomes
probability for what this or that or the
other but it doesn't say what kind of a
device makes a measurement now there's
one school of thought
which has been going on from way back
till the early days of quantum mechanics
vigno in particular promoted this point
of view
that it's a conscious being
observing the system and that means
that's what wheeler believed i believe i
really might have believed quite a lot
of people believe that i think von
neumann had a similar sort of view i'm
not quite so sure about his view but
certainly wigner and i talked to vigner
about this
yeah
i got the feeling from thinking he
wasn't quite as dogmatic he was made out
to be on this issue he just thought this
was a possibility i think
but anyway that's people often refer to
it as the wigner view
that is a conscious being who makes a
measurement that's not my view
my view is that it's almost the opposite
of that view that there is
an objective physical process
which
which deviates from the schrodinger
equation
in which
the state does collapse
so that it becomes one or the other or
the other with certain probabilities
and that this has to do with when
gravity is brought into the picture and
there's reasons for believing this i
don't want to go into that but there is
reason i'd like i'd like you to go into
it if you would be willing to because i
i mean i'm very well it's a very clear
mathematical calculation
there's not a question about it it's
quite what you do with it you see and
what you do with it according to me
is to say okay it tells you that this
system has a lifetime and and it will in
that lifetime become one or the other
without a measurement
it sort of
that's right yes without it what's so
interesting to me that that you're
interested in consciousness and you see
the that consciousness in this
goodell theorem sort of manner
and i would think the most predictable
thing for you to believe as a
consequence of that would be that it is
conscious measurement that collapses the
the the
the quantum indeterminacy the waveform
and yet you don't you think that that it
that statistical
vagueness will collapse into something
that's essentially is it either or is it
binary
was it zero one
the collapse no you mean probably no
there's a probability it'll do well
right right but when the probability
collapses
mean well if it's a two-state system you
see you might have an object which is in
a superposition of here and here yeah
that was direct's first lecture i
remember
and he took out his piece of chalk and
said
and he was talking about atoms you see
according to quantum mechanics
or particles a quantum paragraph can be
here
or it can be here
or it can be an estate which is partly
here and partly here at the same time
and then he took out a piece of chalk
and people tell me he used to break it
in two i can't quite remember because my
mind was drifting away from what he was
saying and i was looking out of the
window and thinking about something
completely different
and unfortunately it only came back
after he'd gone on to the next topic so
i missed the explanation
which was probably a good thing
as i think back on it because
probably the explanation was something
sort of to calm you down and stop
worrying about the problem
i suspect it was something like that so
you don't think that conscious a
conscious observer per se is necessary
to collapse the wave absolutely that is
what i
don't i mean i'm agreeing with you i
don't believe that yes but you do think
that if i'm not
mistaken that
the presence of a of an observer in the
universe
that is to say that or the observation
of the universe by us
is that true to say is fundamental to
the universe
not really
that's that's an interesting question
but it's not part of my view
the world would be there
quite independently of whether they were
creatures
yes of consciousness yes yes walking
around on them yes so can i ask you a
question about that
so it's related to this so
it's my understanding and i could be
wrong about this too because i'm way
afield here you know i'm out of my depth
an area of specialization but
my understanding is that
in some sense as far as a photon is
concerned
that the universe is two-dimensional
perpendicular to its direction of travel
i don't see that now but go on
well i i thought and i thought i thought
that this
mayan it's a consequence of the
contraction of of things as the speed of
light is approached
and so oh i see no no no no that's
that's something you're talking about
the the
lorentz contraction order yeah yeah yeah
well i remember i thought as part of
that that the that part of the reason
that
no amount of energy can propel
something past the speed of light is
because in some sense
the light beam is already where it is
and at its destination at the same time
and you can't get flatter than flat now
the the reason i asked you that though
was because
it pertained to this other question
which was
if you could imagine
what the universe might be like
phenomenally from the perspective of a
light photon that's very unlike the
universe that we perceive
well i see i mean if you if you were
riding on i mean einstein yes i know
riding on a light
the trouble is that um
you can't sit on a light yes that is a
problem but if you do if you were nearly
going you know yeah very very fast like
that the passage of time
you would think it hadn't taken any time
at all right except well and and and
that's the same as being at the starting
point and the destination
yes okay okay so okay okay so
that it now for us we perceive things
with duration and distance
and so but the photon is in the universe
and we're in the universe but the
universe looks very unlike
each of those situational positions
and so you said that there would be a
reality independent of consciousness but
i'm curious
when you think of a reality independent
of consciousness
what what are the attributes of that
reality like is it is a field of quantum
potential is it
uh i'm not quite sure i understand the
question but but
i mean
classically there's no problem i mean
this thing about the contraction and all
that stuff with us going close to the
speed of light and so on this is
classical physics so we're not worrying
really about the problems of quantum
mechanics there
but they're already there in classical
physics but if you had a particle
traveling at the speed of light
let's say just less in the spring of
light than if you could sit on that
particle it would seem as though you got
to your destination almost
instantaneously that's correct
but that's nothing to economic well not
directly right right right that's just
that's relativity right
yes sure but the
the phenomenal universe at that speed is
radically different than the phenomenal
universe at our speed
yeah but the universe is there it's just
a question of
i'm not quite sure i understand this you
see i'm true i'm trying to understand
how it can be all of those things
simultaneously like
no it's
what that means that's not a problem
it's just yeah when i say it's not a
problem what i mean is that there is a
way of looking at relativity which means
special and general relativity which is
completely coherent and doesn't really
worry about
who measures what it's just there you
have a space time which is this
four-dimensional structure may be hard
to understand and visualize and so on
sure but it's the thing which is there
people call it a block universe view
well i think about it as a whole
symphony at once in some sense well if
you like but it's it's all there and
what something measures in that system
you have to go and ask the question if
you had a body traveling with a great
speed and there was a clock on that body
you'd ask for how many ticks does it
happen for one end in the other that's
perfectly well defined if it was sitting
stationary you would have so many ticks
between starting a thing you could have
one which goes out and comes back you
might say only only about four ticks
where's this one that had a thousand
ticks well that's the answer
right in time so it's susceptible to all
those interpretations simultaneously
yeah because each one is just it's only
measuring it with it has it carries the
clock with it and that clock ticks at a
certain rate and that's fine there's no
problem
but i said there's no problem i mean
it's not a philosophical problem there's
a little bit of a problem getting used
to the ideas sure no i agree with that
yeah that's not the issue you can once
you got used to the ideas and you oh yes
you can see time is something which
depends on
how you're moving right and the clock
which is moving
is there any difference between that
statement and
rate of change depends on how fast
you're moving
like is there any difference between
time and rate of change the rate of
change is
because i think of time as the average
rate of change
and so when you say that time
slows down as you move faster you're not
saying much more than as you move faster
you're
the that's just a question you see i
think the mistake here is to think of
time as a as a
an objective
thing yes which is attached to this
model and it's not right there is no
concept of when such an event happens
you say you might say well is this event
later than that event
well if they're what's called space like
separated that is to say
you'd have to go faster than light to
get from one to the other
it's a meaningless statement because
there is no universal concept of time
in this model right it's just not there
i think you see that goes against what
we normally feel about time you think
about time it's progressing and somebody
on the andromeda galaxy we experienced
duration so yes but you see what about
when is now
i often use this i think i use this
example of two people crossing the
street
and they're walking just walking speed
crossing the street
and the question is according to one of
these people
there is a
con
at the same time as they cross each
other there is an event on the the
andromeda galaxy where
space fleet is has been launched and
they're going to invade the earth
according to the other one
the decision has not even been made yet
as to whether they are going to invade
the earth or not now this is only
because you're trying to
transfer your local notion of what you
mean by time to the andromeda galaxy
and this depends on what frame you're
using so if you're using a one moving
frame it hasn't happened yet and the
other one it has
you just have to get used to that idea
that there is no universal notion of
time
ticking away
independently independent frame of
reference yeah
that's right yeah yeah okay okay
can we get you can i go sideways one
more time because i'd like to ask you
like i said i've been wanting to talk to
a theoretical person
forever
i'm really curious about black holes
and so i have this idea
so tell me what you think about this so
um
when a star collapses past the neutron
stage into a singularity
is
and let's say there's multiple black
holes
are they all the same singularity
i don't know
okay okay well i mean you can link up
them somewhere but no we don't
apart from saying we don't know i would
say no they're different singularities
well i i was i was
enclosed that statement and we don't
really know what we're talking about
here but go on okay well well i was i
thought about this
partly god it was so long ago that i
thought about this that i can have her
to even remember what i thought but i
was trying to wrestle with the fact that
you get this
unbelievably intense
not even single point gravitational
field and there are strange
effects
of
there are strange effects of time
inside the event horizon of a black hole
from the perspective of an observer now
if i remember correctly if you were
watching someone descend into a black
hole from outside don't they go slower
and slower then you would you would see
them hovering on the horizon and then
fading away very quickly actually okay
just fade yeah they would fade what what
happens
what happens to their sense of time once
they pass the event horizon compared to
the sense of time the framework well
they would go right through and they
wouldn't notice anything at the horizon
right and what would that look and you
wouldn't be able to see a very big black
hole yeah there's a little one they
would have been
wrecked by the
title forces but yeah if it's a big
enough black hole
you could imagine going through it you
wouldn't even know you'd gone through
the horizon if you could see someone
descending into it how long would it
take them to arrive at the surface
is that forever
not for them no but for you watching
them
but you just see them
you don't ever see inside the horizon
the light can't get out right right
right so you never see that that's right
so they could be
watching their watches and
thinking whoops we've gone through now
and they would do that but you'd if you
could see their watch from outside you'd
see that
the hand slowing down and getting closer
and closer to the moment when they cross
the horizon
but fading out but it would be slowing
down
yes you'd see it slowing down yeah okay
then
if you could see inside
would you see that continuing to slow no
no so i'm not sure what you mean inside
once they pass the event horizon you
can't see them anymore but as they
approach the event horizon if you were
watching them you'd see their clock
slowing yes so if you're outside if
you're outside yeah so then i'm
wondering
you can't tell this but their clock is
going to slow the same way as they
continue moving to towards the black
hole
and that's the trouble you see it's the
wrong way to think of it okay that their
clock is
is there a time which their clock
registers that's going to saying there
is a universal time which everybody is
supposed to respect in some sense
relativity says no
there is no notion but i'm assuming
their their clock would continue to slow
relative to you i'm not trying to assume
an absolute time in the question
i'm just i'm wondering is that as they
approach i know i know the problem that
you can't detect it is the problem here
but
as they're moving towards the star
relevant relative to someone who's
watching them their clocks are slowing
according to this frame of reference
signals that you would receive maybe
that clock
it it emits a little flash of light yes
yes that exactly and you see look those
flashes are slowing down and getting
farther apart yes that's right okay so
then
from the external perspective
i was thinking that it would take them
forever to reach the singularity
and if it takes forever then that would
be the same amount of time that it would
take everything in the universe to
collapse back into the initial
singularity if the collapsing universe
theory is correct
and so the reason there's infinite
gravitation in some sense at the point
of the singularity is because
that's a point at which the end of the
universe is already manifest in the
current universe
and that seems to me that that would be
what would you say in keeping with the
idea in some sense of a block universe
yes i'm not quite sure i see the problem
you're thinking about the whole universe
a collapsing model yes you could
certainly yeah and i i also wondering if
that's a model that you you think is no
it's not my model it's not certainly a
model that people can consider sure
and you might have a an entire universe
which is collapsing inwards yes
and then you would hit the singularity
before you see somebody else hitting it
in those models you were you would
you would find uh you're in trouble and
that your curvature is getting too big
and you could be killed by it as you
were watching somebody else and you see
no no they're happily not nearly there
yet right not nearly there yet that's
what you would that's what you would
okay okay that's okay okay
all right then
your model isn't uh is it a big bang
model with an initial
emergence out of nothing and then
eventually a collapse back to that no no
so okay so how do you conceptualize that
well first of all it is a big bang model
otherwise there is a big bang
but the big bang was not the beginning
the model the treason people have
trouble with this model i think is
you're probably gonna have trouble with
it and you're not unique in this
um
you see people tend to think that if you
have a model in which
it keeps on going in some sense and your
big bang is not the beginning that
you've got to collapse back so it
expands and then it comes back and then
you're back with
but this seems simpler that way yes but
this model is not like that
and that's where you've got to get your
mind around okay
and it's people have trouble and i agree
with it it's a crazy idea and i admit
it's a crazy idea the trouble is it
seems it's quite likely it's true
from certain okay observational things
but it's crazy too it can be crazy and
true at the same time
yeah that's like a definition of light
yes but you see
in this model
the universe expands and it expands and
this exponential expansion we seem to
see the stars seem to be
going starting to go away from us
these very distant stars that people
look at
with an increasing speed right right
seems to be this exponential expansion
and that's what's driven the dark energy
hypothesis that's what they call it's
really it's well i i claim it is
absolutely nothing inconsistent with
einstein's
1917 was it
in
modification if you see that he regards
his biggest mistake but he's probably
actually right
that's to say the introduction of a
cosmological constant right right yeah
he introduced it for the wrong reason
that's true
but
he was right to introduce it even though
he regards his his biggest there's a
real error he needed to make things work
but he didn't have any real practical
reason for assuming that it was true
apart from he wanted the static universe
he didn't like the expansion no that he
didn't no this was a time before
i think hubble had already seen the
expansion but he hadn't quite got
through to einstein how convincing these
results were
so he wanted the universe was just
static and stayed there forever right
right and then he needed the
cosmological constant to do that
that's correct he would need that
however
he was wrong to assume when he got
convinced owner of the universe is
expanding sorry he said oh that was a
mistake my biggest blunder he said
trouble is his biggest smell that turned
out to be true
apparently i mean
this is an argument people don't
necessarily think it was
people might not think it's the
cosmological constant i think it was i
think it's right
i have recent you know internal reasons
for that but let's say
um
that this is right it's a cosmological
constant the universe expands and
expands exponential expansion
now you might ask
who's in this universe eventually not us
the black holes will all have evaporated
away by
walking evaporation there's swallow
galactic clusters what's left in the
universe
pretty well photons
now giving the simplified version of the
theory because because there's some
questions about it still
but let's say it's dominated by photons
which is pretty pretty well true but not
let's take that okay
now the trouble with photons is that
they don't
feel the passage of time right
and
more importantly
the equations governing light
are the wonderful equations due to james
clark maxwell
the maxwell equations
and the maxwell equations have a very
interesting property
that they can't tell big from small
they're what's called conformally
invariant
but if you have a system
in which you've got some electromagnetic
field
and you could stretch this system to
bigger or smaller
it doesn't notice the difference the
equations work just as well and you can
squash them here and stretch them here
well is that in part because space
really doesn't mean anything to a photon
in a sense well it's the scale
you see it's what we call
there's a term which i'll use here it's
called conformal conformal means big and
small
i very much like you we talked about
escher a minute ago there are these
aisha pictures called circle limits
where he describes
what's called hyperbolic geometry but
don't worry about that the most famous
one is these angels and devils and you
see right there's a circular boundary
and they look as though they get smaller
and smaller and smaller as they get to
the edge yes
now as far as those angels and devils
are concerned the little ones are just
the same as the big ones right they
don't know that they're smaller
towards the edge and that to them is an
infinite universe
but to us we can see no there's this
infinity
which is just sitting there
and
these angels and devils if they
don't know big from small
i'm not sure
i have a bit of trouble using this to
explain things because they
the angels and devils do have a size in
the picture but you see if they were
made of massless material that wouldn't
know big from small
so if they were made of just
electromagnetism
then big and small are equivalent and so
you wouldn't know when you got to the
edge of this universe
so that infinity is just like anywhere
else
that's the difficult concept of this
thing that the photons
reach infinity without realizing without
realizing anything funny has happened if
you put it like that
infinity
in this conformal picture
is just like anywhere else it's only
mass that knows the difference
if you want to build a clock
you need mass
and this comes from the two most famous
equations
of 20th century physics
and the two most famous equations one of
them is einstein's e equals m c squared
of course which tells us that energy and
mass are equivalent
and the earlier one was neat it was um
max planck's
e equals h nu or e equals hf whatever
right you call the frequency which tells
you the energy and frequency are
equivalent
put the two together that tells you mass
and frequency are equivalent
so that means that if you have a mass
it is a clock it has a frequency
simply determined by its mass
and this fact is really the basis of
modern clocks which are extraordinarily
precise
they don't directly give this because
the frequency is much too high you have
to scale it down but roughly it's the
same idea so clock a mass is a clock
but the other side of that coin
is if you don't have any mass you don't
have any clocks so you're not having
time you don't have any time scale you
don't have any distance measure so if
the world is inhabited only by massless
things say photons
then it doesn't know big from small it
doesn't know hot from cold
and so the idea is and this is where you
have to take a deep breath
as opposed to all the other parts of
this conversation the idea is
that the remote future
is indistinguishable from a big bang
so long as there is no mass around
now the remote future the reason you
have no mess around is basically well
listen there's a complicated part of the
argument yeah let's say it's because
it's mainly photons that's good enough
what about the other way what about the
big bang well there's lots of mass there
surely
but the thing is at the big bang things
get so hot
things are moving around so fast if you
like
that the
energy or the mass energy mass hyphen
energy the
concept of mass according to einstein
is almost entirely in their motion
and then the mass becomes more and more
irrelevant
the closer you get to the big bang
so again you have a situation where mass
is effectively zero
so are you
are you is it your
claim belief theory that
when things ground out in a universe
that only consists of electromagnetic
radiation that that is now a
precondition for an event like the big
bang
incense yes i'm saying that the physics
which is going on
at the very remote future
is extraordinarily like the physics
going on at the very beginning
i'm i'm going to end them when i say
beginning i only mean the big bang
because it's not really the beginning
yes yes
well it's such a lovely place to end and
we have been going for an hour and a
half and i don't want to wear you to a
frazzle i'm not frazzled well i i think
i might be would do
do you mind if i just asked
go ahead and steve please
one of the things that i'm um
very struck by in your account of
the three realms of of matter
mind and mathematics
roughly speaking is that
is that the realm of mind
or consciousness is
they're not the realms are not reducible
one to another so the realm of mind
cannot be reduced simply to the realm of
matter nor can the realm of mathematics
be reduced simply to
uh the realm of matter they each have
their own existence well you see it's
it's a picture which i've used i'm not
sure whether it
completely concurs with my current views
but go on well
what i what i wanted to ask you about is
and it's a two-part question but i'll
start with the the first here and that
is that
what is the relationship it appears as
though there's a fundamental intrinsic
relationship
between
the realm of our consciousness our
thinking on the one hand and the the
realm of mathematics or let's say
intelligible
reality
um
that uh
i'd like to hear
you
comment on i mean just to to maybe see
this a little bit you know the
philosopher plato as you well know and
you often describe this realm of
mathematics as a platonic realm
it
had a theory of of recollection and we
can regard that as a myth or whatever
but it does appear at some very profound
level that it's true that that we we
come to
we couldn't come to understand things
that have an intelligible reality like
mathematics if they were not
already somehow in us or potentially in
us in the patterns or structures of our
own
conscious consciousness
um
so i'm wondering if you
if you could say a few words about
the the relationship between our
thinking or the realization of our
thinking it's development and
uh the realm of the mathematical or
more broadly speaking you might call it
intelligible reality or however however
you might want to construe that that
realm
are we talking about the perception of
mathematics or things
let's start with that yes the
possibility of understanding yes the
possibility of understanding mathematics
gosh
so what i actually have lost the threat
of the question oh so really the
question is what is it do you believe
there is is there an intrinsic
relationship that appears to be between
our thinking our the realm of
uh consciousness
and the realm of
mathematics or intelligible reality
independent of us
but intrinsically are those realms
intrinsically related
well i think i'm trying to say that we
can access
the truths of mathematics with our
consciousness
how we do that i don't know
but somehow we can access
that world
and of course
some people find it easier than others
and this is a difficulty in trying to
talk about these things it's a question
for richard dawkins lately
yes and that that the risk of going uh
going out too far uh i i want to just
make it an effort at
relating this question to to the to the
to the work of dr dr peterson one of the
things that um
dr peterson has clearly
shown is that there are many many people
who
are not it's called the for some people
are the short-handed call this the
meaning crisis many many people who are
finding they don't they simply don't
have the
the resources to make sense of their
lives in a way that seems to be adequate
to the demands of their own
self-consciousness
and
so you know at the heart of human life
has has evolved as creatures that are
evolved and self-conscious is clearly
finding
a way of understanding ourselves in the
world that is adequate to the demands of
that very self-consciousness and and
life has no
the what life is as meaningful is
precisely to to answer that demand of
ourselves as a self-conscious creature
and
um one of the things that it seems to me
that very much that uh is at work at
this at least some profound level is it
is the idea that that everything is
reducible simply to materiality that as
it were eliminates any substantial
reality to our own consciousness if that
were true it would just be a
epiphenomenon um but it also denies the
existence of of an independent realm of
spirit as some philosophers would say or
of intelligible reality or simply put it
in in terms of the mathematical and so
what i'm what i'm
wondering about and it's maybe an
outrageous question to ask a physicist
but you have written
many and many beautiful books that are
clearly related very much to this very
question um that has to do with the
nature of of of of human realization
that is say how we come to understand
ourselves um
in in in in the in in the world and what
i'm what i'm trying to drive to here is
is whether you have thoughts on
the nature of the realization of our
consciousness we could call that simply
human realization as a shorthand
and about the
question like what might constitute the
fact of intelligibility
right there's a there's a capacity for
us to to reflect this structure that the
mathematical structure the physical
structure we
and and that seems to be part of what
you described as understanding
it's like
perhaps you're um formulating a question
about the metaphysics of that
intelligibility
yes or we could simply say
sir roger in your
observation and and uh reflection uh
what are the forms of of of
life and culture
that appear to facilitate that deep
human realization that appears to have a
intrinsic relationship between our
selves as self-conscious creatures and
the nature of what is independent of us
and that does seem to be to be at the
heart of the question of meaning that dr
peterson has
been working on and perhaps helped
others to think about
i mean i i'm
not quite sure i've grasped the question
here but it has to do with
people's
i mean this relationship between
conscious beings and this
this world of mathematical platonic
world if you like and it's certainly
something which
people differ very much and how easily
they
make that contact if you like and i
certainly have made attempts to try and
explain to people who are not used to
thinking about
mathematics if you like to to
to gain a little bit in that
understanding of what's going on in
mathematics so
that's that's how successful or not i
don't know but at least an attempt to
well
thank you yes as a follow-up to that
question
do you intuit or or think or
believe that
that
in that realm of
the mathematics as you might say
intelligible reality
do you think other things might also be
included in that let's say um
truth
generally or love or or beauty
are
because of course the dominant view
right now is that these are simply
constructs of the human mind or culture
it's another way of saying the human
mind or
material forces that are at work that
have given rise to these contracts but
don't actually have any independent
reality themselves
do you think that there is a kinship or
perhaps that mathematical reality or
truth is
part of a realm that that exists as
independently as mathematics do i think
there's an
i believe i have in some places that
have to think where it is
adorned this picture with the the
platonic world being part of a bigger
picture
which has to do with
other things than you see that's to do
with truth if you like but there's a
question of beauty or other qualities
and i think that may be relating to the
question you're raising here
i don't have much to say about it but i
do i do remember drawing a picture
somewhere i can't even remember where
now in which this platonic world was
part of a larger
body of
things like
beauty for example and qualities of
virtue in fact also things qualities
which are
things that our consciousness is
concerned with and very important
but not quite what i've been talking
about which is a very specific thing yes
understanding mathematical truth yes so
i certainly would agree
that it's there's more to it than that
and i think that's what you're telling
me and i and i'm i'm going along with
that it's just that i didn't know what
to do with it i think that's that's the
trouble
yes well i the reason i i ask is because
it it does seem to me that if these
two things are connected let us say that
the nature of what we are and think that
we are
is somehow intrinsically according to
its own let's say structure or nature
uh connected i mean we might even say i
mean
if human beings have no no nature
there's sometimes which mathematics
itself is not even possible i mean
certainly not for us i mean it seems to
be we have to we have an innate capacity
uh to varying degrees as you say to
think these thoughts or
perceive these realities but if that
realm
is say the realm of mathematics is part
of a larger realm in the way that you've
just
just said
and it is related intrinsically to
to what we are that our
self-perception and self-consciousness
has a structure such that it
it calls out for in some sense
an understanding of these things or an
understanding of ourselves in relation
to those those those those realities it
does seem to me that human realization
has to be thought very fundamentally
through from
that starting point
yeah well
i think all i can say here is that i
have considered that in places
i could probably find a transparency
that i used to use to talk whether i can
find a place in something i've written
i'm not so sure but i certainly did
consider
the platonic
you know truth if you like it was really
more like truth
beauty and morality
in in that in that order that's a good
question i think if i could find what i
whether there wasn't a word and what
there wasn't all that yeah what would
and
when you say morality in that sense i
mean truth and beauty in some sense
that's more apprehensible than morality
do you have any idea why your intuition
drove you to place morality at the
at the outermost part of that i could
not agree whether even i did or not okay
so that that
i'd have to
rake through all the things i'd
i suspect there must be an article
somewhere where i did that but i do
remember using it in talks yes
so so this would be addressing
the remarkable it's more that i don't
really
have anything that i can say
i can say okay i like things i like ba
for instance
i'm very fond of that very much and it
says certain
i think particularly with music there
are things which which i can
relate to very much but in order to make
it anything
that i can talk in a rational way
about i sort of i give up there because
i'm not good enough at right talking
about things right yeah
oh yes we're doing this that way it was
i'm so happy that you agreed to talk to
me well i hope it was was of some use to
you yes
but um some of these things i think
that's difficult to describe and
clearly it's it's
particularly these things with with the
big bang and all that which is
an idea which
we do seem to see evidence
for something signals
you see there could be signals coming
through from the previous eon as i call
it
and i think we see them
this is my colleagues of mine you have
to throw that in at the end
well what do you mean
oh well yeah they've been exp
you see i used to go around giving talks
about this stuff very often i thought
this is fine i can do that nobody will
ever know whether i'm wrong or not and
so i can talk about this forever
and i thought i wonder if that's right
and i thought well first thing i thought
about was collisions between
supermassive black holes
i mean our galaxies and collision course
with the andromeda galaxy
it has a black hole much bigger than
ours
after we collide and set things settled
down a bit
our poor little black hole gulp down by
it and there will be enormous
gravitational waves going out carrying
away some proportion of the significant
proportion
of the mass energy in in the two objects
being
concerned here
and maybe they could be detected by
different people maybe they can be
detected in the next eon
gravitational waves can get through from
one to the next
this is clearly according to the model
they can so various people
try to search for these things mainly my
colleague vaheguru zajan who is a
armenian
and some other polish people who later
get on it and they had a much clearer
calculation of what they regarded as the
probability that these signals were
really there
and 99.4 percent confidence level i
think they got
if they are yes that they're there
some people didn't believe it because
they don't believe the model of course
but then more importantly more recently
this is a paper
mainly one which came out in the
monthly notices of the royal
astronomical society
about a year and a half ago and we claim
that we see
what we call hawking points
that would be
after one of these galactic clusters
gets swallowed up by black hole there's
nothing left but this black hole it
evaporates away by hawking evaporation
all that radiation doesn't even begin
until so late
that by the time it comes into the next
eon it's a little tiny point
that little tiny point over 380 thousand
years spreads out
there's a little bit of an argument
about how far it spreads out but what we
seem to see is it spreads out to about
four degrees cross which is about eight
times the diameter of the full moon and
that's what we see
so we see within now a bigger confidence
level
99.98 there is an argument now which
is to do with whether the actual size we
see is consistent with expectations and
there's interesting questions about that
but ignoring that point
we have a 99.98 confidence level
that they're there
the spots there's little spots of raised
temperature
and we see them
and why are they there
what are they doing there according to
current theory they shouldn't be there
according to the theme i put forward
yes they should be there and they're the
result of
the remote future of a galactic cluster
you're probably propagating itself into
the next eon
the radiation yes it's the radiation the
hawking radiation probably which comes
from the black hole and all this mass
gets concentrated into that ray and that
comes with a little tiny point
which by the time you see it
is spread out to
about eight times the diameter of the
moon
and we see these spots and they've seen
they're seen both in the more
sophisticated
planck satellite
data
and if you look at the
like what is it now the five strongest
points in the blank data
and look in the earlier w map that's a
different satellite completely different
and you find these spots exactly the
same places
in the wmap data there's a sixth one in
the wmap data which is just about as
strong as those five look back in the
planck data and that's there too
so those six points
i claim are genuine hawking points as
i'm calling them
and there's no other explanation for
them that i know of
they're seen and they are
independently confirmed by another group
who weren't claiming they don't see
anything but they do see
they see evidence for these spots too
you just look at the data
okay what's the reason for it any
current current cosmology
i can't see any explanation for them
this model predicts them
i haven't seen any response from the
after a year and a half from the
established
cosmology community
published in a very respectable journal
it's probably the leading journal
for astrophysical processes
there is an error but
in this which is rather curious but i
don't want to go into that
but it doesn't it doesn't uh much
whether the confidence level should be
reduced a bit i think that's probably a
case for that but not much because the
signal is pretty strong
thank you very much that was a that was
something man
well just to bring us to a close here
sir roger it's been a great honor to
speak with you today i know for both me
and dr peterson thank you so very much
for your time it's been my pleasure
[Music]
you